[Music]
when a team of archaeologists recently
came across some 15,000 year old human
remains
they made an interesting discovery the
teeth of those ancient humans were
riddled with holes their cavities were
caused by the same thing that still
plagues us today specific tiny microbes
that live in our mouths these microbes
are with us soon after birth we
typically pick them up as babies from
our mothers mouths and as our teeth
erupt and they naturally begin to
accumulate communities of bacteria
depending on what we eat and
specifically how much sugar we consume
certain microbes can over populate and
cause cavities diets high in sugary
foods caused an explosion of bacteria
called mutants streptococcus E in our
mouths like humans these microorganisms
love sugar using it as a molecular
building block an energy source as they
consume it the bacteria generate
byproducts in the form of passes such as
lactic acid the mutant streptococcus II
are resistant to this acid but
unfortunately our teeth aren't while
each human tooth is coated in a hardy
protective layer of enamel it's no match
for acid that degrades the armor over
time leaching away its calcium minerals
gradually acid wears down a pathway for
bacteria into the tooths secondary layer
called the dentin since blood vessels
and nerves in our teeth are enclosed
deep within at this stage the expanding
cavity doesn't hurt but if the damage
extends beyond the dentin the bacterial
invasion progresses causing excruciating
pain as the nerves become exposed
without treatment the whole tooth may
become infected and require removal all
due to those sugar loving bacteria the
more sugar our food contains the more
our teeth are put at risk
those cavemen would hardly have indulged
in sugary treats however so what caused
their cavities in meat heavy diets there
would have been a low risk of cavities
developing because lean meat contains
very little sugar but that's not all our
early human ancestors ate cavemen would
also have consumed root vegetables nuts
and grains all of which contain
carbohydrates when exposed to enzymes in
the saliva carbohydrates get broken down
into simpler sugars which can become the
fodder for those ravenous mouth bacteria
so while ancient humans did eat less
sugar compared to us their teeth were
still exposed to sugars that doesn't
mean they were unable to treat their
cavities though archaeological remains
show that about fourteen thousand years
ago humans were already using sharpened
Flint to remove bits of rotten teeth
ancient humans even made a rudimentary
drills to smooth out the rough holes
left behind and beeswax to plug cavities
like modern-day fillings today we have
much more sophisticated techniques and
tools which is fortunate because we also
need to contend with our more damaging
sugar guzzling ways after the Industrial
Revolution the human incidence of
cavities surged because suddenly we had
technological advances that made refined
sugar cheaper and accessible today an
incredible 92 percent of American adults
have had cavities in their teeth some
people are more susceptible to cavities
due to genes that may cause certain
weaknesses like softer enamel but for
most high sugar consumption is to blame
however we have developed other ways of
minimizing cavities besides reducing our
intake of sugar and starch in most
toothpastes and many water supplies we
use tiny amounts of fluoride that
strengthens teeth and encourages the
growth of enamel crystals that build up
a tooths defenses against acid when
cavities do develop we use tooth
fillings to fill and close off the
infected area prevent
from getting worse the best way to avoid
a cavity is still cutting down on sugar
intake and practicing good oral hygiene
to get rid of the bacteria and their
food sources that includes regular tooth
brushing flossing and avoiding sugary
starchy and sticky foods that cling to
your teeth between meals gradually the
population of sugar loving microbes in
your mouth will decline
unlike the cavemen of yesteryear today
we have the knowledge required to avert
a cavity calamity we just need to use it
Oh
[Music]